en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste
d'une longue dégringolade de notre
posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriels aussi les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supplétifs au service des
états unis ou bien des alliés et de
véritables partenaires
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 5 octobre
mobilisation partout en france pour
alerter le gouvernement sur l'urgence
sociale 200 rassemblements à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats pour notamment
l'augmentation des salaires contre la
réforme des retraites et celle de
l'assurance chômage entrée en vigueur
pourtant la semaine dernière des france
est aujourd'hui minée par l'inflation et
la flambée des prix de l'énergie et rien
ne semblait rassurée pas même les
mesures d'aidé exceptionnelles annoncées
par l'exécutif alors qu'attendent les
manifestants nul gouvernement sommes
nous à l'aube d'une grogne sociale bien
plus importante décryptage avec nos
invités dans quelques instants
à la une également la visite d' anthony
blinken à paris premier déplacement d'un
responsable américain depuis le début de
la crise des sous-marins selon les
mobiliser pour contribuer à restaurer la
confiance entre la france et les
etats-unis mais beaucoup de travail
reste à accomplir après la perte du
contrat du siècle alors quels enjeux
pour ce déplacement en france du chef de
la diplomatie américaine quelles
décisions concrètes attendues par paris
pour repartir sur de bonnes bases avec
washington les questions sont sur la
table
[Musique]
la france qui tente également de déminer
des relations avec un autre pays
l'algérie très en colère après les
propos d' emmanuel macron publié par le
journal le monde le président français
qui a accusé le système politico
militaires algériens d'entretenir une
rente mémorielle sur la guerre d'algérie
alors comment faire retomber les
tensions avec lg qui a notamment décidé
de fermer son espace aérien aux avions
militaires français
et de rappeler son ambassadeur à paris
on en parlera en troisième partie des
missions
[Musique]
à presque six mois de la présidentielle
ils veulent remettre le social au coeur
du débat les syndicats cgt fo solidaires
ou encore fsu appelait à la mobilisation
nationale ce mardi avait plus de 200
rassemblements sur l'ensemble du
territoire on retrouve notre reporter
katia technique depuis la place de la
république à paris
bonsoir katia est ce que la
manifestation de l'intersyndicale
a été suivie aujourd'hui
oui effectivement un c'est fanny puisque
25 mille personnes selon la cgt ont
répondu à l'appel de cette
intersyndicale donc fo cgt fsu et
solidaires et d'organisations étudiantes
et deux jeunes de lycéens alors quels
que soient les chiffres en tout cas ce
rassemblement c'est très très forte
mobilisation animant scorta jacky et
elle est la place de la république où je
me situe actuellement jusqu'à la place
de l'opéra eh bien il traduit la
préoccupation des syndicats aujourd'hui
en cette rentrée d'ailleurs il
s'agissait d'une interprofessionnelle et
cela signifie que de très nombreux corps
de métiers étaient présents des filets
et demander des choses au gouvernement
il y avait une éducation énergie
transport pour ne citer que ceux là
alors au titre des revendications
évidemment la précarité les inégalités
entre les hommes et les femmes le
pouvoir d'achat bien sûr l'abandon de la
réforme des retraites puisque à six mois
de la présidentielle on est toujours
dans le flou que souhaiterait galles
réellement emmanuel macron aura-t-il le
temps de l'imposer et puis également
sujet crucial les augmentations de
salaire en négociation actuellement pour
parvenir à des accords de branche qui ne
donne pas satisfaction selon les
syndicats je vous propose d'écouter
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt ainsi que jacques borenstein
secrétaire adjoint de france ouvrière il
ya tellement de surenchère sur les
retraites et en vue des élections
présidentielles qu'il faut toujours être
prudent sur les déclarations des uns et
des autres mais vous connaissez notre
position sur la réforme des retraites
c'est surtout pas celle que nous
proposait le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe alors j'ai vu qui est
maintenant qu'il est plus premier
ministre il va plus loin puisqu'il
propose de travailler plus longtemps
évidemment on est contre cette mesure
c'est une mesure stupide stupide devenir
un problème
de salaire dans ce pays tout le monde le
reconnaît maintenant il était temps ce
que ça fait un moment qu'on dit et donc
sur les questions salariales sur les
questions d'emploi ont fait des
propositions au gouvernement depuis des
mois et des mois et pour l'instant ce
qu'on constate c'est tout ce qu'on a
applaudi tout ce qu'on a appelé les
deuxièmes lignes notamment n'ont
toujours pas vu leurs salaires
revalorisés hormis la revalorisation
automatique du smic on est mobilisé pour
faire pression bien sûr sur les salaires
mais sur l'arrêt de toutes les contre
réformes et aujourd'hui non seulement
les salaires ne sont pas augmentés on en
parle mais de plus la réforme de
l'assurance chômage frappe de plein
fouet ceux qui sont déjà précarisées et
super précarisés par les conséquences de
la crise sanitaire
alors les syndicats ont promis de
multiplier les actions un peu plus tard
et deux s'opposent également à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qu'elle
est déjà entrée en vigueur parallèlement
aujourd'hui des grèves dans les
transports ont eu lieu donc ça donne un
avant-goût du rapport de force qui va
s'installer dans cette rentrée merci
katia technique en direct de la place de
la république à paris le changement de
stratégie de communication de l'exécutif
face à cette grogne sociale qui ne
faiblit part on en parle tout de suite
avec alexis poulain dans son édito ce
soit
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous à six mois de la présidentielle
donc mobilisation pour remettre les
questions sociales dans le débat
salaires assurance chômage on l'a vu
retraite pourtant il ya eu quelques
augmentations de salaire ici ou là les
professeurs notamment dans la fonction
publique la réforme des retraites elle a
été reportée ça va si mal que ça oui oui
ça va c'est mal d'ailleurs cette
mobilisation elle est en pointillé il
n'y a pas une grande mobilisation on
voit bien que les syndicats la houle à
un mode d'opération qui n'est peut-être
pas suffisamment efficace face au
rouleau compresseur qu'est le maquereau
nisme parce que ce que veut faire un
menu macron c'est passer des réformes
extrêmement injuste avant la fin du
quinquennat la réforme des retraites qui
a été mise en pause par les syndicats
justement qu'ils pensaient qu'elles
n'avaient pas lieu d'être et le co vide
la réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
est passé par décret alors même que le
conseil d'état avait dit que c'était
peut-être pas le moment tout ça c'est
des réformes qui vont contre les plus
pauvres les plus précaires même si
évidemment quelques salaires ont été
augmentés parce qu'il le fallait ça fait
tellement longtemps que les salaires de
fonctionnaires ont été gelés que ça
commençait à se voir qu'on ne pouvait
plus vivre avec son salaire les gilets
jaunes rappelez vous c'est ce mouvement
qui commence parce que on a beaucoup de
français dans ce pays qui ne peuvent pas
joindre les deux bouts qui travaillent
et qui ne peuvent pas finir le mois et
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose on remet
évidemment la question du pouvoir
d'achat la question qui est central de
dire mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
vivre avec un salaire et beaucoup de
français prennent de plein fouet c'est
mesure ces réformes qui sont soit disant
progressistes mais qui en réalité plonge
dans la précarité de nombreux français
alors attaqué un par les oppositions
l'exécutif mais met en avant son bilan
pour montrer que le quinquennat a
profité à l'ensemble de la population il
faut bien le dire que les chiffres de
l'insee vont plutôt dans ce sens un du
progrès du pouvoir d'achat sous le
quinquennat macro c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est l'insee
emmanuel macron clairement il veut
effacer son image de président des
riches alors oui c'est ça lui colle à la
peau mais parce que c'est vrai l'insee
d'ailleurs c'est le site était en rade
aujourd'hui j'ai voulu aller voir
justement un seul c'est dommage oui
c'est très dommage
mais il sait qu est ce qui se passe vous
faites un peu une facebook aujourd'hui
c'était un bon mais il ya des chiffres
qui sont là et qui disent que ça va
mieux apparemment on peut gagner plus
d'argent sous mac row elodie la réforme
de la taxe d'habitation a bénéficié à
plus de 17 millions de français oui la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation ces 200
euros de plus dans la poche de quelques
français la réforme de l'isf l'impôt sur
la fortune qui se transforme en impôt
sur le patrimoine immobilier c'est à peu
près trois cent trente mille français
qui eux ont gagné neuf mille euros
toutes les réformes des manuels macro
ont profité aux plus riches en réalité
et vous avez des sondages qui passe un
peu comme la température à vous avez la
température réelle des températures
ressenties vous avez ce que pense
emmanuel macron qui vit dans un pays
fantasmé où il dit j'ai fait des
réformes pour le poire d'achat et puis
le pouvoir d'achat ressenti et là les
français ils sont majoritairement à se
dire que les réformes des menus macron
ont amputé leur pouvoir d'achat que ça
ne va pas mieux et d'ailleurs aucune
réforme aujourd'hui n'a bénéficié à
l'économie on attend de voir les
résultats il n'y a jamais eu de
ruissellement et des quelques réformes
qui ont été faites ont certes dans les
chiffres l'insee bien sûr les tableaux
de calcul des certitudes conseil
emmanuel macron lui-même pense que ça va
bien mais peut demander aux français à
ceux qui font aujourd'hui la queue
devant les banques alimentaires aux
banques alimentaires qui manquent de
bras qui recrutent des bénévoles
tellement la demande a explosé plus de
huit millions selon des associations 2
millions en début d'année des français
qui n'avaient jamais fait appel aux
banques alimentaires avant cela les
étudiants qui font aussi la queue pour
se nourrir c'est ça augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des gens qui sont dans la
paupérisation extrême non je crois pas
donc il ya vraiment deux mondes le monde
des modèles macron où tout va bien vous
voulez le meilleur président du monde où
ça va extrêmement bien et puis le pays
dans lequel vivent les français qui
visiblement n'est pas le même que celui
des modèles maquereau ou là le ressenti
n'est pas du tout le même alors on a
beaucoup parlé évidemment de
l'immigration en sept ans on est bien
rendu compte mais le vrai enjeu des
présidentielles ça sera justement le
pouvoir d'achat oui je crois que ces
débats sur l'identité sur l'immigration
ses biens cédés débat d'intellectuels de
saint germain les français s'en foutent
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
veulent savoir qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer parce que si on nous demande de
rembourser la dette qu'ovide qui est
catastrophique
si on demande de faire des efforts sur
les finances publiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle est le maquereau est
en campagne donc il fait des cadeaux des
promesses à tout le monde la réalité
c'est qu'après sa réélection s'il est
réélu ou peu importe qui va arriver aux
commandes de ce pays il va retrouver
vers un pays endetté à l'extrême un pays
avec des services publics mais à à
genoux regardez aujourd'hui c'est pas
3000 soignants qui ont été mis à pied
c'est beaucoup plus 1400 rien qu'à en
ile de france l'hôpital public qui se
demande s'il va pouvoir assurer sa
mission les professeurs qui ne savent
plus comment faire pour assurer les
missions de service public tout ça c'est
le pays dans lequel on vit en réalité
donc non ça va mal évidemment et les
français le ressentent et aujourd'hui le
plan à part les promesses de campagne il
n'y en a pas et c'est ça qui est
extrêmement dangereux je pensais ce
hiatus entre ce que pensent les élites
la majorité au pouvoir et ce que vivent
les français et c'est pour ça qu'on a
autant de monde dans la rue alors pas
avec les syndicats ça a été très peu de
monde aujourd'hui mais quand on lutte
contre le pass and i terre quand on
lutte pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est elle
et gilet jaune ils ne sont pas morts
loin de là et je crois qu'on va voir au
contraire un regain de ce mouvement
parce qu'on se rend compte que les
promesses de campagne ne suffisent pas
aujourd'hui l'inflation est réel les
produits de première nécessité explose
le logement explose l'énergie on en
parlait la semaine dernière les prix
d'énergie explose et rien n'est fait par
les pouvoirs publics pour empêcher cette
catastrophe sociale merci beaucoup
alexis poulain en direct donc éditorial
sur rt france et ses manifestations dont
2 ce mardi intervient évidemment en
pleine hausse des prix de l'énergie
sujet ô combien brûlant à six mois de la
présidentielle jean castex qui promet
la semaine dernière un bouclier
tarifaire avec le blocage du tarif
réglementé du gaz jusqu'en avril et la
limitation de la hausse de l'électricité
nadège abderrazak la france une cocotte
minute prête à exploser c'est en tout
cas la crainte de l'exécutif et pour
cause 18 mois après le début de la
pandémie les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité s'envolent plus 57 % pour
le gaz depuis le début de l'année et 12%
pour l'électricité en février prochain
traumatisé par la crise des gilet jaune
qui avaient émergé pour moins que ça à
l'automne 2010 8 l'exécutif veut à tout
prix éviter la naissance d'un mouvement
social de la même ampleur les français
n'ont pas à prendre de plein fouet cette
augmentation des prix du gaz nous
assurerons notre rôle de protection des
français face à la flambée des prix de
l'énergie une protection a minima et pas
pour tous les français pour les plus
modestes seulement une rallonge de 100
euros pour les 5,8 millions de ménages
est déjà bénéficiaire du chèque énergie
et parce que c'était logiquement loin
d'être suffisant le premier ministre a
annoncé la création d'un bouclier
tarifaire nous mettons en place un
bouclier tarifaire concrètement pendant
tout l'hiver prochain le tarif du gaz ne
dépassera jamais le niveau d'octobre
2021 la facture de chauffage des
français auraient dû augmenter de 30%
cela n'arrivera pas bloquer les prix
chaprais augmentation jusqu'en avril
2022 autrement dit jusqu'à la prochaine
présidentielle et donc l'éventuelle
réélection d'emmanuel macron ces gros
pour être vrai et pourtant il y en a
marre de leur comme il y en a marre
depuis le début de l'année les prix
augmentent et c'est seulement maintenant
qu'il se réveille parce qu'on est à six
mois de l'élection présidentielle mais
ils nous prennent pour des imbéciles ou
quoi ces gens là les français n'ont pas
besoin de mesures est électoraliste mais
d'une baisse réelle et durable du prix
des énergies et de l'essence des
mesurettes électoralistes à en croire
donc une partie de l'opposition qui
estime que le gouvernement peut et doit
mieux faire avec 600 euros de plus sur
la facture de gaz l'aide de 100 euros
annoncé par le goût en nommant n'est
clairement pas à la hauteur de la
gravité de la situation même son de
cloche du côté des syndicats le
gouvernement doit d'abord regarder des
mesures ciblées pour les ménages les
plus modestes il faut sans doute encore
augmenter le chèque énergie élargir ceux
qui sont éligibles en particulier aux
franges des salariés qui sont un peu au
dessus des critères actuels il y a déjà
une forte précarité énergétique dans
notre pays beaucoup de gens qui ne se
chauffent pas où se chauffent mal
pendant l'hiver ça provoque des
situations terribles c'est un problème
majeur pour les ménages et la
perspective de reprise risque de se
heurter à la stagnation des salaires et
l'augmentation des factures pour faire
face à cette hausse du prix des énergies
l'association de consommateurs ufc que
choisir propose pour sa part une baisse
temporaire de la tva elle prend exemple
sur l'espagne où elle a été réduite
temporairement de 20 à 10% il y à des
mesures structurelles à prendre on ne
voit pas la légitimité d'une telle taxe
si on l'avait supprimée cela aurait des
gonfler la facture est à la hausse du
prix des énergies s'ajoutent les
réformes controversées une protestation
toujours aussi vive contre le passé ni
terre où la vaccination obligatoire pour
certains professionnels un nouvel appel
à manifester qui témoigne de la grogne
sociale qui s'accentue et cela dans tous
les secteurs et face à la gronde sociale
l approche an de la présidentielle les
candidats multiplient donc les
propositions pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des français le premier ministre
s'est engagé à l'assemblée nationale
agir sur le levier fiscal notamment sur
le prix des gazons bien l'entendre en
clair baisser les taxes alors quelle
solution adopter arrêter le matraquage
fiscal comme l'affirmé aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national augmenter les
salaires quoi qu'il en coûte comme le
préconise plusieurs candidats à gauche
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
tu es avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau julie en double porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir je viens
donc merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
françois cocq porte parole d'arnaud bon
de bout en bout au bon soir françois
sort merci d'être avec nous on le voit
on semble découvrir effectivement dans
ce pays qui est un problème de pouvoir
d'achat avec l'augmentation aussi dans
le même temps des de l'électricité le
gouvernement qui répète quand même à
l'envi 1 2 études à l'appui de l'insee
que le pouvoir d'achat augmenter durant
le quinquennat macron qui croire y at il
vraiment une menace déjà inédit tu viens
odoul sur le portefeuille des français
aujourd'hui l'heure est grave l'heure
est grave oui alors sur les chiffres et
la propagande gouvernementale on peut
s'interroger puisque les 8 %
d'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
finalement sont confrontés à un autre
sondage d'opinionway qui montrent que 60
% des français considèrent que leur
pouvoir d'achat a été dégradée depuis
2010 est donc exactement un problème il
n'y a pas qu'un problème de pouvoir
d'achat il ya aussi un problème de
précarisation et de pauvreté l'insee
publié dernièrement que pour l'année
2019 soit avant la crise qu vide avant
la crise économique liée à la crise
sanitaire il y avait 13 millions de nos
compatriotes qui vivaient sous le seuil
de pauvreté 13 millions de nos
compatriotes
évidemment c'est un chiffre terriblement
inquiétant pour la sixième puissance du
monde je rappelle quand même des
d'autres réalités il ya un français sur
trois qui n'arrivent pas à se soigner
pour des raisons économiques il ya un
français sur cinq qui ne fait pas trois
repas par jour pour des raisons
économiques et une autre étude aussi
inquiétante que 46 % des étudiants
sautent des repas également pour des
raisons économiques et à cette situation
on a l'impression que ce gouvernement
regarde ailleurs regarde ailleurs et
n'apporte pas les bonnes solutions les
bonnes solutions c'est quoi c'est rendre
du pouvoir d'achat aux français leur
rendre de l'air est arrêté évidemment le
matraquage fiscal et là le gouvernement
1 un moyen clair c'est pas seulement les
salaires c'est surtout ce qu'on leur
retire ce qu'on leur retire tous les
mois avec les charges avec l'électricité
avec le gaz avec les sens et tout ça
c'est principalement des taxes nous
rassemblement national demandons depuis
des années à l'assemblée nationale avec
nos députés dessus prix une aberration
fiscale typiquement française qui est la
tva sur la taxe sur les carburants la
télé c'est peu ce qui permettrait
d'alléger pour un plein de 50 euros de 5
à 6 euros à la facture c'est important
et le gouvernement refuse d'actionner
cette possibilité on va rentrer dans le
détail justement des solutions mais tout
d'abord sur ce diagnostic françois cocq
contre le pouvoir d'achat plutôt pour le
pouvoir d'achat on a tout essayé en
france ajouté monsieur macron fait le un
bilan de gratte papier tout simplement
il nous parle de données macro qui n'ont
pas de sens qui sont en dehors de toute
réalité en tout cas de la réalité qui
est celle non pas que ressentent les
français mais que vivent les français
voyez il suffit de regarder ses fils
désespérante de jean ses fils qui
s'allonge devant le secours populaire de
ces étudiants qui sont obligés de venir
se nourrir collectivement parce qu'ils
n'ont plus les moyens de se nourrir
pardon est-ce que c'est pire qu'avant
bien évidemment que c'est pire qu'avant
regardez ce que je vous dis très
concrètement de maman de manière très
palpable ces filles qui s'allonge mais
si vous voulez on repart sur les
chiffres regardez cette augmentation de
17 % du prix d'électricité en trois ans
cette augmentation en un an du prix des
loyers de près de 20% et puis cette
augmentation du prix de l'énergie qui
est totalement dramatique enfin bon le
gouvernement n'est pas sérieux regardez
je vous prends je vois jouer danger
mondial en soi non non non je vous
prends un chiffre écoutez bien une
famille qui est au tarif régulé de
l'énergie elle dépense chaque année 849
euros de gaz là avec les augmentations
qui sont celles de ces six derniers mois
elle va en avoir pour 308 euros de plus
et le gouvernement vient nous dire la
main sur le coeur qui va restituer sans
euro il n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et finalement il ne restitue pas
aux français ce qui leur a pris dans la
poche avec les taxes qui sont celles qui
les maintient sur l'énergie pourquoi ne
pas engager aujourd'hui une baisse de
cette fiscalité baisser la tva et la
ramener à 5 5% pourquoi pas mettre en
place une telle paix flottante sur sur
sur l'énergie aie sur le gaz comme ça a
été le cas à une époque sur sur le
pétrole et sur l'essence enfin bon les
solutions existent et on a des gens qui
ne veulent pas se saisir de la situation
et qui sont aux manettes alors justement
le disais à six mois de la
présidentielle les candidats multiplient
les propositions le veau de votre
poulain arnaud montebourg 1 par exemple
l'ancien ministre de l'économie qui a
détaillé les points de son son programme
regardé face à l'envolée des prix du gaz
et de l'électricité je défends le
blocage des prix la tva réduite à 5 5%
au lieu de 20% l'augmentation des
salaires inférieurs à 2000 euros net par
mois avec + 10 % sur le smic et
négociations par branches sur le reste
de l'échelle des salaires julien en
double est ce qu'elle vous paraissent
crédibles ces propositions présentées
par arnaud montebourg et son
représentant et c'est ce soir ben vous
savez nous on regarde avec intérêt les
propositions d'arnaud montebourg on peut
se rejoindre sur de nombreux points sur
le constat sur je dirais la volonté
évidemment de rendre du pouvoir d'achat
aux français sur une mesure extrêmement
concrètes que nous avons en commun avec
un nombre de boer qui est la
renationalisation des sociétés
d'autoroutes voilà qui a été un immense
une immense escroquerie depuis 2006 et
surtout c'est le patrimoine des français
qui a été spolié c'est des péages qui
ont explosé ces dernières années marine
le pen souhaite que ce patrimoine
reviennent aux français et ce qui
permettrait d'abaisser le tarif des
péages de 10 à 15% une autre mesure
extrêmement concrètes qui rendrait
immédiatement du pouvoir d'achat aux
français c'est la privatisation de
l'audiovisuel public et y en a bien
besoin quand vous voyez que des laurent
ruquier ou d'autres journalistes de
france inter se permettent de faire de
la politique avec l'argent des français
avec les impôts des français il ya bien
besoin finalement que l'état se
désengage financièrement de
l'audiovisuel public ce qui rendrait
quand même 3 milliard d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat à 28 millions de foyers fiscaux
ce qui est énorme donc c'est vrai que
sur ces mesures là on n'entend pas le
gouvernement évidemment au contraire au
contraire depuis cinq ans pratiquement
cinq ans on assiste à une saignée à la
fois social et fiscal on assiste à des
réformes totalement ubuesques comme
celle de l'assurance chômage qui va
pénaliser les chômeurs en faisant
baisser en moyenne de 17% les
allocations de 40 % des chômeurs donc
accentuer la précarisation tout ça c'est
le bilan du gouverneur les 10% et avant
de rendre la parole à françois lecoq
coop pardon sur les 10 % de
l'augmentation du smic c'est vrai qu'il
ya un débat dans le pays certains
économistes nous disent que ça va
plomber l'économie notamment les petites
entreprises quelle est votre position au
rassemblement national mais sur le smic
j'ai accepté c'est un faux débat c'est
un faux débat parce que c'est déjà
toujours ce qu'on avance en campagne
c'est un je dirais un épouvantail de
communication touche on essaye de
toucher au smic on apporte des chèques
énergie voilà pour pallier cette cette
crise aujourd'hui qui était manifeste
mais clairement les classes moyennes
dans notre pays sont matraqués matin
midi et soir qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
rendre de l'argent et un peu d'air aux
classes moyennes dans notre pays rien le
gouvernement a donné beaucoup pour les
plus fortunés ça c'est sûr avec
notamment la suppression de l' isf avec
ce ruisseau helmand qui n'en était pas
un oui les plus fortunés ont profité de
la politique de macron les plus
précaires n'ont pas profité et les
classes moyennes sont matraqués matin
midi et soir
il ya une vraie discussion et je croyais
à un vrai point de désaccord stratégique
stratégique entre nous l'augmentation du
smic immédiate je dis bien immédiate de
10 % pour commencer et ensuite on met
autour de la table l'ensemble des
partenaires pour aller plus loin puisque
il faut toucher à l'ensemble des
salaires qui sont en dessous de 2000
euros nets non pas par moi dans ce pays
c'est à dire 60 % aujourd'hui des
salariés on va devoir reconstruire
l'ensemble des échelles des salaires
dans ce pays et bien ce travail il faut
s'y atteler et c'est pas une mesure est
comme ça qui est posée entendez quand le
président du medef monsieur roux de
bézieux dit lui même qu'il va falloir
augmenter les salaires parce qu'il voit
bien qu'il est contraint par l'activité
économique et par le déséquilibre qui
est celui qui existe aujourd'hui entre
le travail et
et là il a financé la manière dont tu es
financer l'économie et bien il va
falloir reprendre la main il va falloir
le il va falloir reprendre le contrôle
sur cette question là et c'est une
différence de crois que nous avons
monsieur monsieur oudoul vous dites
rendre du pouvoir d'achat mais rendre du
pouvoir d'achat d'une certaine façon
c'est prendre dans la poche gauche
défense est ce que vous allez leur
rendre dans la poche droite la mesure
qui est préconisée par arnaud montebourg
et qui consiste justement un changement
de structure autrement a eu entre man 10
à une augmentation du smic dans un
premier temps mais une revalorisation de
l'ensemble de l'échelle des salaires
cette mesure là elle touche à la
distribution dans ce pays de cela je
compte jouer je comprends qu'elle vous
gêne
pas parce qu'elle est compliquée qu'on
ne peut pas la mettre en oeuvre un
moment dans ce pays en falloir s'atteler
aux choses s'y atteler en profondeur et
ne pas se contenter de dire
effectivement qu'on met des pansements
ou des rustines comme c'est le cas avec
les différentes allocations qui sont
aujourd'hui proposés à mais on a on est
tout à fait d'accord sur le point que
les rustines n'apporte rien d'un point
de vue de du pouvoir d'achat des
français là ce que je ce que je vous dis
c'est que on peut leur rendre tout de
suite immédiatement déjà en évitant de
le reprendre parce que les français
évidemment qu'il veut gagner plus mais
surtout husky calcul à la fin du mois
c'est ce qu'ils doivent donner en impôts
et en taxes et en charge obligatoire
aujourd'hui quand vous cumulez que ce
soit l'énergie les sens les hausses des
matières premières et autres les
déplacements aujourd'hui j'étais
aujourd'hui vous savez que dans la
ruralité vous avez dû journée sans
voiture il ya pas besoin d'être à paris
pour des journées sans voiture vous avez
des français qui ne font plus le plein
d'essence parce qu'ils n'ont plus les
moyens et quand ils vont au supermarché
c'est soit le plein de courses soit le
plein d'essence pour ça donc ça il faut
leur rendre tout de suite et ça le
gouvernement peut le faire avec la
baisse des taxes il peut le faire aussi
avec des mesures extrêmement concrètes
que j'ai pu évoquer sur des dépenses qui
ne sont pas obligatoires sur aussi ça
c'est peut-être un point de désaccord
sur le coût de l'immigration sur le coût
de l'immigration qui nous coûte un
pognon de dengue à la fois d'un point de
vue social d'un point de vue sécuritaire
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons plus donc il
faut rendre de l'argent aux français en
instaurant la priorité nationale
notamment pour le logement puisque vous
parliez justement des loyers qui ont
explosé quand vous avez 31 % des ménages
et d'heureux d'origine étrangère fin
étrangers qui bénéficient du logement
social et que vous savez que 13% des
français qui bénéficie du logement
social il ya une discrimination il ya
une préférence étrangère il faut
remettre les choses à l'endroit et que
les français soient prioritaires pour le
logement non là où là où vous évoquer la
question des taxes vous comprenez bien
qu'on pouvait agir ponctuellement il le
faut je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas il
le faut mais par contre vous devez
changer la structure des choses comment
changer la structure des choses sur la
question de l'énergie aujourd'hui en
allant taper à bruxelles parce que
bruxelles ça suffit maintenant ce marché
de libéralisation de l'énergie au sénat
qui est à l'origine aujourd'hui de cette
augmentation des prix il ne faut pas
croire que l'augmentation des prix tombe
comme ça par pas par enchantement donc
il faut se donner le moyen de reprendre
le contrôle à tout moment on ne peut pas
agir simplement ponctuellement en se
disant on verra bien demain et on fera
une autre mesure à ce moment là et bien
comment agir a stratégiquement comment
se donner une visée d'entraînement pour
l'ensemble du pays en disant aux gens le
socle de notre de notre vie individuelle
et collective c'est la dignité que nous
avons tous par le travail que nous
faisons et qui nous permet de faire
vivre les nôtres et bien cette dignité
du travail elle doit être récompensée
elle doit être revalorisé c'est ce qui
permet de bien vivre de bien vivre
individuellement et collectivement et de
se protéger de tout ce qui nous entoure
et finalement qui sont les professeurs
et les cas pas les accapareurs dont
l'union européenne est aujourd'hui l'un
des chefs de file sur cette question de
l'énergie notamment je viens en double
les taxes ok on est sûr on les supprime
quand on les réduit en tout cas et la
dette qui augmente inlassablement la
dette qui augmente vous savez la dette
elle s'étale et puis la dette c'est
aussi les choix politiques la dette
c'est de l'investissement la dette c'est
peut-être l'investissement sur une
filière qui est un atout formidable pour
notre pays qui est le nucléaire parce
que le prix de l'énergie aussi c'est des
choix politiques c'est le choix des
énergies faussement renouvelables qui
aussi nous coûte un pognon de dingue
c'est des choix à la fois européen
mais aussi nationaux il pas augmenté
l'état est exactement mais enfin je veux
dire les éoliennes on pourrait en parler
pendant des heures mais c'est une
escroquerie environnementale qui nous
coûtent très cher et qui aussi qui
dévastent nos paysages mais aussi qui
polluent parce que les éoliennes sont
évidemment arrimé à du moteur thermique
ou le voit avec l'exemple allemand qui a
une pollution 15 fois supérieure à celle
de la france donc tout ça c'est des
choix politiques marine le pen souhaite
remettre les choses à l'endroit même du
bon sens le bon sens c'est quoi c'est ce
qu'ils constituent des atouts pour nous
c'est ce qui apporte de l'énergie sûre
fiable et moins cher parce qu'on a la
chance d'avoir le nucléaire qui garantit
une facture deux fois moins importante
que celle des foyers allemands tout ça
c'est les choix politiques et sa marine
le pen y est engagée pour le prochain
mandat soit qu'arnaud montebourg sur ce
point arnaud montebourg entend proposer
des ruptures ordonnée autrement dit il
faut rond avec des effets de systèmes
qui sont ceux auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui mais nous ne
pouvons pas partir à l'aventuré les gens
sortent d'une période atrocement dur
nous ne sommes pas encore totalement
sorti avec avec le co vide avec la crise
économique qui est devant nous on doit
profiter de ce moment pour rompre avec
ce qui doit l'être humain doit le faire
de manière ordonnée simple à la roue les
candidats avec un effet avec un effet
d'entraînement et de ce point de vue là
les mesures qui sont proposées par
arnaud montebourg par exemple sur la
question écologique puisque puisque vous
y venez c'est de dire aujourd'hui il
faut faire la sortie des énergies
carbonées la sortie du pétrole eh bien
on peut faire la sortie du pétrole en
vingt ans de fait faire ce choix là ce
choix prioritaire la de la sortie du
pétrole ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
arrêter le nucléaire comme ça
aujourd'hui du jour au lendemain et que
donc on va on va le on va le maintenir
parce qu on doit faire les choses les
unes après les autres à un moment donné
il faut cette vision là c'est ce qui
manque aujourd'hui dans la vie politique
où les jours ne sont pas en train de
courir après un lièvre électorale ou
alors après des mesurettes parce qu'ils
ont toujours aujourd'hui un temps de
retard sur la réalité du quotidien des
français merci à tous les deux julien au
dos la françois cocq d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france ce soir
paris washington tente toujours de
recoller les morceaux après des semaines
de brouilla emmanuel macron a reçu
anthony blinken aujourd'hui trois
semaines après l'annulation du méga
contrat sur l'achat de 12 fumeurs un
français par canberra un tête à tête
suivi par un entretien entre le chef de
la diplomatie américaine et son
homologue français jean yves le drian
anthony blinken
à paris pour encore deux jours ils
participent à des réunions organisées
par l' ocde l'organisation de
coopération et de développement
économiques alors les américains soit il
instaurer la confiance après ce coup de
poignard écoutez l'analyse de régis le
sommier grand reporter chez air france
les etats unis aujourd'hui sont dans une
situation où est la france considère
qu'elle a été véritablement offensé par
l'attitude américaine dans le cadre de
la mise en place de l'alliance au cuss
pour la zone indo pacifique et 7,7 mise
en place de cette alliance s'est fait
justement au détriment de la france la
france a vécu véritablement comme une
gifle le fait de se voir finalement
subtiliser un contrat de 56 milliards de
dollars c'est-à-dire un des pubs le plus
gros contrat d'armement signé les
accords des 50 dernières années pour
fournir à l'australie une dizaine de
sous marins ces sous-marins évidemment
seront remplacés par des sous-marins
américain à propulsion nucléaire la
france dans le même temps a subi
d'autres revers faut pas oublier au
niveau de ces contrats d'armement c'est
que la france est toujours le troisième
exportateur d'armes au monde mais qu'
elle devait fournir à la suisse un
certain nombre de rafale à l'allemagne
et que ces rafales également ont été
remplacés par des f 35 américain ok une
véritable pression des états unis sur un
certain nombre de ses alliés pour
acheter son armement et évidemment ça
s'est fait au détriment de la france
alors coup de tonnerre coup de colère
chez emmanuel macron jean yves le drian
est monté au créneau plusieurs fois
expliquant qu'il y avait véritablement
une rupture quelque part les
ambassadeurs ont été rappelé
l'ambassadeur de france en australie
l'ambassadeur de france aux états unis
alors ce n'est pas la première fois que
la france
rappelle ses ambassadeurs dans le cas
d'une crise diplomatique mais en
l'occurrence c'était la première fois
que ça se produisait avec les états unis
est avec l'australie donc là
actuellement on est dans le creux de la
vague on est dans une situation où
emmanuel macron et joe biden se sont
parlé au téléphone ils doivent
s'entretenir à la fin du mois d'octobre
en europe probablement à l'occasion du
g20 à rome
mais cette visite de binkè nord faut
quand même préciser qu'i et blinken
pickens et le secrétaire d'état
américain il est francophone il a passé
plusieurs années à paris il considère la
france comme son deuxième pays donc ce
n'est pas rien évidemment c'est on
envoie les états unis ont bien senti un
malaise ils envoient leurs secrétaires
d'état et en plus un secrétaire d'état
très très francophile en juin dernier
jean yves le drian lui avais dit
bienvenue chez toi
certainement pas c'est certainement pas
le ton qu'il a adopté aujourd'hui quand
il l'a reçu d'ailleurs il n'ya pas une
conférence de presse
et direction à présent les états unis où
une bataille politique se joue en ce
moment congrès américain sur le plafond
de la dette et c'est l'opposition
républicaine qui bloque actuellement le
vote on en parle avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas il ne reste que quelques
jours donc avant cette échéance très
importante pour l'économie américaine
oui du côté du gouvernement américain
les discours sont alarmistes avec cette
catastrophe annoncée pour la date du 18
octobre prochain c'est la date butoir
avant laquelle le plafond de la dette
américaine doit être relevé sinon il ya
des risques de récession c'est en tout
cas ce qu'affirme la secrétaire
américaine au trésor janet et jelen est
là était donc très alarmiste dans un
discours prononcé à la ddte elle que ce
serait catastrophique que les etats unis
soient dans une position où nous
manquons de ressources pour payer les
factures du gouvernement parmi les
conséquences en effet d'un défaut de
paiement de la part des états unis et
bien il y aurait le fait que cela
pourrait entraîner des retraites un non
versés ou encore des militaires non
rémunérés ou même des familles qui ne
toucherait plus les aides de la part de
l'état alors le plafond de la dette des
états unis aujourd'hui est fixé à 28
mille milliards de dollars et d'habitude
c'est plutôt une formalité de relever ce
plafond de la dette qui permet aux états
unis d'investir à crédit ce plafond de
la dette a déjà été relevé près de 80
fois depuis les années 60 mais cette
fois donc il y à une opposition de la
part des républicains au congrès et
c'est pour cette raison que joe biden a
finalement pris la parole est lui aussi
un discours assez catastrophiste écoutez
le
soyons clair non seulement les
républicains refusent de faire leur
travail mais ils menacent d'utiliser le
pouvoir leur pouvoir pour nous empêcher
de faire notre travail sauver l'économie
d'un événement catastrophique
je pense très honnêtement que c'est
hypocrite dangereux et honteux leur
obstruction et leur irresponsabilité
ne connaissent absolument aucune limite
en particulier au moment où nous
débattons pour sortir de cette pandémie
le locataire de la maison blanche qui
dit ne pas pouvoir garantir à l'heure
actuelle que les états unis ne seront
pas en défaut de paiement d'ici la fin
du mois d'octobre alors si les
républicains bloquent ce vote pour
relever le plafond de la dette c'est
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas distille et
bien donné carte blanche à joe biden
pour ses différents plans
d'investissement il estime que les
démocrates devraient faire les
manoeuvres eux-mêmes écouter ce qu'en
dit notamment le chef de file des
républicains au sénat
ce gouvernement démocrate unifiée du mal
à gouverner
il n'a même pas pu adopter le projet de
loi bipartite sur les infrastructures
que le président à négocier et le
président de la chambre a promis qu'il
serait adopté la semaine dernière
la majorité doit cesser de sombrer vers
une autre crise évitables les démocrates
doivent s'attaquer au plafond de la
dette
nous leur avons donné une feuille de
route et un préavis de trois mois je
suggère que nos collègues se met en
mouvement
vous avez entendu ce parlementaire
républicain pousser les démocrates à
agir eux mêmes parce qu'il existe en
réalité une procédure pour laquelle les
démocrates pourraient en effet parvenir
à relever le plafond de la dette sans
l'aval des républicains mais c'est une
procédure très fastidieuse très longue
et on n'est même pas certain qu'elles
pourraient aboutir avant donc cette
fameuse date butoir du 18 octobre
prochain alors évidemment c'est les
etats-unis se retrouvent en défaut de
paiement cela aurait des conséquences
terribles pour l'économie américaine et
plus généralement pour l'économie
mondiale est en réalité elle est publics
n'ont pas véritablement intérêt à ce que
justement cette situation arrive on
comprend justement dans l'intervention
du parlementaire que vous venez
d'entendre qu'il s'agit aussi et
peut-être surtout d'une manoeuvre
politique de la part du camp républicain
pour semer la division au sein du clan
démocrate on sait qu'il y a aussi des
négociations très difficiles sur les
plan d'infrastructure et les réformes
sociales souhaitée parole camp démocrate
et bien le fait de relever le plafond de
la dette américaine est un autre moyen
de faire pression pour les républicains
évidemment l'enjeu pour eux et c'est
d'affaiblir le camp démocrate en vue
notamment des élections de mi-mandat qui
je vous le rappelle auront lieu au mois
de juin l'année prochaine merci beaucoup
thomas abonnés en direct de washington
une fronde anti bei den 1 au congrès
américain que vient de décrire thomas
qui s'organise aussi dans certains états
illustration texas aux états sudistes 1
par excellence qui a promulgué pas moins
de 600 loi qui contredisent celles de
l'administration fédérale
le texas soit un mouvement nationaliste
rêve même d'indépendance
mehdi est ce qui fit un t'excite aux
états unis est il possible
cette conception de la sortie du texas
du territoire américain pour le moment
théorique refait surface depuis quelques
semaines l'un des fondateurs du
mouvement nationaliste texan a estiment
que la période actuelle n'a jamais été
aussi favorable pour engager des
démarches indépendantiste ils rêvent
plus que jamais devoir noter que ça
sortir des états unis nous vivons un
moment de l'histoire où les peuples
demandent leur indépendance partout dans
le monde en écosse en catalogne au
kurdistan mais aussi ailleurs les gens
veulent se gouverner eux mêmes et ne
plus l'être par des bureaucraties
technocratique et lointaines
principale raison de cette volonté
l'aspect économique
chaque année le texas verse plus de 100
milliards de dollars pour le budget
fédéral et au delà de cette contribution
un autre point irrite les
indépendantistes texan les décisions du
pouvoir fédéral centralisée
je pense sincèrement que nous nous
orientons vers une sécession je vois de
plus en plus de gens qui se demandent
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a donc en commun
avec les gens qui vivent dix ans à new
york il ne peut pas y avoir de
coexistence pacifique entre deux visions
de la vie complètement différente et des
visions du gouvernement de commandes
gérons nos affaires on ne peut pas être
embarqué dans ce conflit désespéré sans
renoncer à quelque chose en cours de
route
cet état américain de 29 millions
d'habitants est le seul du pays à avoir
été une république indépendante entre
1836 et 1845 laps de temps où il s'est
séparé du mexique pour rejoindre ensuite
les états unis par le biais d'un traité
une particularité historique qui
donnerait donc des idées aux texans
d'aujourd'hui d'après le président du
tnm près de 400 mille partisans
soutiendrez l'indépendance si le texas
était un pays nous serions la neuvième
puissance économique du monde nous avons
des usines de l'énergie et une
agriculture
rien ne manque le texas est soumis aux
décisions d'un gouvernement fédéral
centralisée qui lui impose ses lois ses
règles et ses normes
mais pour obtenir son indépendance le
texas a encore un long chemin à
parcourir pour une sortie légale le
président du parti nationaliste texan a
lancé l'introduction d'une pétition dans
la primaire du parti républicain une
requête sur la question d'un référendum
d'indépendance qui devra absolument
recueillir au minimum 70 7000 signatures
pour que celle ci soit inscrite au
bulletin de vote lors des primaires un
scrutin qui se tiendra en mars 2022
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston au texas justement aux
états unis avec dave perkins analyse
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on vient de
le voir votre état le texas ait traversé
donc par des velléités indépendantistes
ça vous surprend vous avez senti cette
colère monte notamment l'élection de joe
biden
qui quand ils sont content lorsqu'il a
quitté le parti démocrate
je n'ai pas quitté mon parti c'est le
parti qui m'a quitté
et c'est à ce moment que les démocrates
aux états unis ont arrêté d'être des
patriots et sont devenus un parti
démocrate de gauche internationaliste
socialiste voire communiste et ce parti
ronald reagan ne pouvait plus il
travaillait car cela allait à l'encontre
de ces principes en tant que
l'américain et je pense que le texas en
état ce même point que ronald reagan on
ne peut pas continuer à être ce que le
parti démocrate veut que nous soyons car
le parti démocrate a une idée de du
texas et qui est totalement en
infraction vis-à-vis de l'histoire a été
principe des états unis et donc il faut
se presser et défendre ce que l'espagne
ont toujours été
ce que le texas fait en ce moment et
j'espère que nous encourageons d'autres
personnes à suivre notre exemple ça veut
dire clairement qu'il y a vous estimez
en tout cas côté que ça s'il ya un vrai
décalage entre ce que vous vous vivez et
le pouvoir de washington
surtout si les démocrates selon
washington
convaincu je pense que c'est une bonne
description les personnes c'est un
endroit différent un tube est la preuve
en est le nombre de personnes qui sont
passées que californie d'autres états de
gauche
jusqu'au texas jusqu'en au climat
jusqu'à d'autres états de l'ouest qui
ont cette même image c'est vraiment
après imputation les mouvements
migratoires disent tout ce qu'il ya à
dire sur la californie qui est trop à
gauche et le texas qui est un lieu
accueillant
où les états unis sont toujours tels
qu'ils sont et on respecte toujours là
de la constitution selon vous c'est un
sentiment purement texan ou
ce sentiment et ses velléités
indépendantistes elle pourrait créer des
émules peut-être dans d'autres bastion
républicain aux états unis
je ne pense pas que le texas est à la
pointe d'un mouvement je ne pense pas
qu'on ait besoin d'un chef d'une pointe
à ce mouvement je pense que plusieurs
sept ans attirent les gens
tout simplement par affinités
tu fais du respect pour la constitution
et par l'amérique traditionnel millau ce
n'est pas vraiment l'indépendance texas
textures au texas et le traditionalisme
le respect de la constitution et de
l'histoire américaine date de plus qu'il
ya plus de deux siècles nous souhaitons
pas perdre ces choses ce n'est pas un
désir d'indépendance certains désirs ne
pas perdre ce que nous avions
voici ce qui est le moins l'auteur de ce
mouvement ce qui fait de nous des
importantes east
certaines personnes voudraient que nous
restions
tous solidaires
beaucoup d'états quitte le mouvement
général qu'elle reste fidèle à aux états
unis on en parlait avec notre
correspondant aux états unis à quelques
instants une autre bataille politique
sur le plafond de la dette on a entendu
joe biden se plaindre que les
républicains faisait obstruction et
empêcher les démocrates de véritablement
faire leur travail qu'est ce que vous
répondez pour votre défense de
républicains
tout à une seconde du lycée de bottes
qui veut dire truchot son souhait bling
pour aller à paris meaux crac répandent
des mensonges dans les médias c'est une
première - vous ne faites aucun vote
républicain serait nécessaire dans les
deux chambres pour relever le plafond de
la dette c'est faux les démocrates ont
une majorité de cas de 34 à la chambre
des représentants c'est une égalité au
sénat les la vice-présidente
remporté la majorité il pourrait relever
le plafond de la dette celle d'après
midi mais il préfère présenter la
situation comme les requins ne tient
donc pas gênant pour l'adoption de cette
fois cela la ram est d'éviter
les reproches après avoir adopté cette
loi préfère donc ne pas l'adopter mais
il préfère même que ça publics invoquent
pour cette loi et pour prendre ce
pouvoir valdes quand il faut dire que
c'était une vote
partisan et que donc les conséquences
puissent être partagées mais cela va
renforcer l'inflation il y aura beaucoup
de conséquences négatives ce sera une
très mauvaise chose deuxième mensonge
il serait nécessaire de nous retrouver
en défaut de paiement si on ne relèvera
le plafond de la dette dit si l'on ne
relève pas le plafond de la dette cela
signifie qu'on ne peut dépenser que ce
qu'on gagne au niveau du gouvernement
fédéral et on peut donc continuer à
rembourser les dettes en cours cela ne
signifie pas forcément un défaut de
paiement cela signifie qu'il faudra
ajuster les priorités dans les dépenses
et ajuster et diminuer certaines
dépenses mais les démocrates était
stimulé les dépenses adore son était
donc ont pour eux la seule alternative à
relever le plafond de la dette c'est le
défaut de paiement mais ce n'est pas
vrai ils n'ont pas besoin non dans celle
républicain et le défaut de paiement
n'est pas inévitable donc ce sont les
deux mensonges répandus dans les médias
merci d'être perkins à d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous apporter votre point de
vue en direct sur rt franches
elle a récemment quitté facebook
emportant avec elle des milliers de
pages d'études internes réalisés par
l'entreprise documents qu'elle a
transmis à différents régulateurs
américains et aux médias français ça aux
gaines c'est son nom a témoigné ce mardi
devant le sénat américain cette ancienne
employée est à l'origine d'une série d'
enquête qui démontre notamment que
facebook est conscient des dangers
provoqués par ces applications elle
assure que l'entreprise ait passé ses
profits avant la population écoutez je
m'appelle français ça haugen j'ai
travaillé chez facebook j'ai rejoint
facebook parce que je pense que facebook
et a le potentiel de faire ressortir le
meilleur de nous mêmes mais je suis ici
aujourd'hui parce que je crois que les
produits de facebook nuisent aux enfants
alimente les divisions et affaiblissent
notre démocratie
la direction de l'entreprise c'est
comment rendre facebook et instagram
plus sûres mais ne fera pas les
changements nécessaires car ils ont fait
passer leurs profits astronomiques
avant les gens une action du congrès est
nécessaire ils ne résoudront pas cette
crise sans votre aide
hier nous avons vu facebook être retiré
d'internet je ne sais pas pourquoi il a
été mis hors service mais je sais que
pendant plus de cinq heures facebook n'a
pas été utilisé pour creuser les
divisions déstabiliser les démocraties
et faire en sorte que les jeunes filles
et les femmes se sentent mal dans leur
corps est un témoignage qui tombe plutôt
très mal pour la firme de mark
zuckerberg au lendemain d'une panne
géante qui a affecté pendant plusieurs
heures des milliards d'utilisateurs dans
le monde un black out qui pose la
question de la toute puissance du groupe
récit des événements liés à ce bug
mondiale et ses conséquences avec
nicolas petit
il est près de 17h heure française
lorsque les sites et applications de
facebook instagram et whatsapp ne
répondent plus pris de court et alors
que le problème ne peut être résolu dans
l'immédiat la communication de facebook
se limite à un tweet publié dans la
soirée par son directeur technologique
qui se confond en excuses étant de jouer
la montre finalement dans la nuit après
de longues heures de coupure le retour à
la normale peut progressivement se faire
mais pour certains experts c'est sur ce
quoi qui fera date
non seulement leur site et est hors
ligne et leur capacité à réagir à
communiquer publiquement et à faire ce
qu'il faut lors d'un incident match
comme celui ci était également appellée
il n'avait pas de plan de secours
lorsque quelque chose comme ça arrive il
vous devez savoir quel est votre plan de
secours au lieu de l'an pro visé et on
ne dirait pas que facebook avait
réfléchi à quoi de faire face à ce genre
de situation
pour le lanceur d'alert eduardo dun
cette faille qui serait dû à un problème
de routeurs et affecté plus de 3
milliards et demi d'utilisateurs
pose plus largement la question du
monopole de facebook dans notre société
la panne simultanée de facebook whatsapp
et instagram semble être un exemple
facilement compréhensible et populaire
des raisons pour lesquelles le
démantèlement d'un certain monopole en
au moins trois morceaux pourraient ne
pas être une mauvaise idée dans son
rapport publié ce mardi matin facebook
dit ne pas avoir de preuve que les
données de ses utilisateurs et aient été
compromises à la suite de cette panne
mais lundi soir très vite ce bug ya eu
des répercussions sur le groupe à wall
street les actions de facebook ont
plongé de 4,89 % et la fortune de son
patron mark zuckerberg a fondu de 6
milliards de dollars cette gigantesque
panne a par ailleurs profité aux
messageries concurrentes signalé
télégramme télégramme est ainsi passé de
la 56e à la cinquième place des
applications gratuites télécharger aux
états unis
vous avez que fabrice epelboin un
professeur à sciences po spécialiste des
réseaux sociaux bonsoir fabrice epelboin
merci d'être avec nous comment expliquer
qu'un mastodonte dans tel que facebook
ait pu disparaître d'internet et surtout
pour une durée aussi longue
ce sont des choses qui arrivent dans les
plus grandes entreprises sauf que
habituellement ça n'a pas un impact
aussi spectaculaire que quand c'est
facebook qui du jour au lendemain
disparaît des écrans six heures pour
reprendre l'activité s'est
exceptionnellement long effectivement il
ya lieu de s'interroger sur la
préparation de facebook à cet événement
mais des incidents techniques tels que
celui qui a connu facebook ça peut
arriver et toutes les entreprises s'y
préparent toutes les entreprises
sérieuses y prépare à travers ce qu'on
appelle un plan de reprise d'activité
alors vous dites ça peut arriver certes
vous avez raison fabrice est pas loin
sauf que quand c'est facebook et bien ça
ça crée une sacrée pagaille
l'occasion peut-être de de démontrer
s'il le fallait une nouvelle fois cette
superpuissance
peut-être trop
l'occasion de démontrer la dépendance de
chacun d'entre nous aux outils fournis
facebook la dépendance de beaucoup
d'entreprises aux outils qu'offre
facebook pour faire la relation
clientèle notamment il ya des pays comme
l'inde où facebook est presque synonyme
d'internet et où des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises se sont
retrouvées paralysées parce qu'elle
était totalement dépendante de facebook
ou de whatsapp ou les deux et puis
l'occasion réalisé que on utilise
beaucoup facebook pour se connecter à
d'autres services et que le jour où
facebook n'est plus là on n'a plus accès
à ses autres services et ça on pourrait
tout à fait ce que des cachets notre
service en utilisant de fausses de
choses qu'un un login password et c'est
l'occasion de se rendre un peu moins
dépendante facebook mais c'est aussi
l'occasion pour les initiateurs de
réaliser que effectivement comme le
souligne edouard ce modèle il est temps
de démonter cette entreprise et de la
rendre un peu moins dangereuse
effectivement les centaines de millions
d'appareils notamment demandant l'accès
au serveur facebook ont provoqué des
ralentissements plus globaux d'internet
il ya eu véritablement un impact mondial
ça manque justement là faire dépendance
qu'on a avec ces géants
on a une dépendance très forte avec
sévillan est encore facebook ce n'est
rien si on regarde la dépendance avec
des infrastructures des choses que la
population générale le réalise pas trop
mais qui sont fondamentales qui sont les
autoroutes d'internet on a en france
comme ailleurs une dépendance énorme
avec des entreprises telles que amazon
et ses services cloud
énormément d'entreprises si les services
cloud d'amazon venaient à défaillir
s'effondrer du jour au lendemain en même
temps qu amazon et tous ceux tout cette
globalisation d'internet qui sont faits
à travers les gars fans représente une
dépendance considérable et il est
vraiment temps de regarder sans passe il
est vraiment temps de savoir quoi faire
en cas de défaillance de l'un de ses
prestataires géant et de réfléchir à des
alternatives et de reprendre une forme
d'autonomie et de souveraineté alors
justement les alternatives c'est parfois
la concurrence et elle a été plutôt
servi hier soir en la concurrence à
facebook ou à 108 heures twitter signal
justement et surtout télégramme qui est
passé de la 56e à la cinquième place des
applications gratuites les plus
téléchargées
c'est bientôt la fin du monopole
facebook ça l'a prouvé peut-être hier
soir alors en tout cas pour ce qu'elle
est messagerie instantanée il est clair
qu'il est infiniment préférable
d'utiliser des technologies telles que
signal ou télégramme qui offrent
rigoureusement les mêmes services que
whatsapp que d'utiliser whatsapp qui est
un vrai danger pour les données
personnelles ça a été prouvé il ya peu
qui renforce ce monopole et qui ne
sécurise pas ses utilisateurs tels que
peuple faire des messages est tel que
télégramme et bien plus encore signal
merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
tentera de comprendre comment les
relations paris lg en plus autant se
dégrader ces dernières semaines au
centre de la colère algérienne la
restriction des visas pour le maghreb
décidées par paris mais aussi une
critique du système politico militaires
algériens lancé par le président
français
[Musique]
le résultat d'un joueur peut réserver
bien des surprises pour mieux comprendre
où vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pg légende
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la ligue
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
elle serait de retour en france
l'inflation en un an les prix à la
consommation ont augmenté d'1 9% selon
les dernières données de l'insee vous
avez aujourd'hui une impression qui est
plus due à une désorganisation simuler
des circuits de production et des
circuits de distribution plutôt que une
réelle inflation de la demande
l'inflation ressentie par les ménages ne
correspond pas forcément
à l'inflation qui est mesuré par l'insee
tout ce qui est pris l'énergie loyer et
ses terrasses qui pèse très lourd dans
le budget des ménages qui sont en bas de
l'échelle sociale du coup se retrouvent
sous-estimé par ces instituts
conjoncture c'est quand même assez clair
que pour moi c'est un chiffre qui est
archi politique donc de marketing
politique
il pourrait quand même s'ils le
voulaient parce que c'est pas très
compliqué avoir des méthodes qui serait
un petit peu plus réaliste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon le
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et épaules vers moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en développement sur partout
partout vous avez construit des vignes
décarbonés pour des usines roues on
n'aimait rien du tout comme carbone dans
l' usine que ça soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans dans le monde
donc là la conscience écologique aussi
existe en russie
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la france qui tente de déminer
les relations avec l'algérie très en
colère après les propos d' emmanuel
macron publié par le journal le monde le
président français qui a accusé le
système politico militaires algériens
d'entretenir une rente mémorielle sur la
guerre d'algérie alors comment faire
retomber les tensions avec l'algérie
pays qui a notamment décidé de fermer
son espace aérien aux avions militaires
français
et de rappeler son ambassadeur à paris
réponse dans quelques secondes
la france et d'algérie sans fond style
donc dans une crise diplomatique
dernière sortie en date qui accentue les
tensions entre paris et alger des propos
d' emmanuel macron dans les lignes du
journal le monde le président français
qui a critiqué le système politique
algérien un discours jugé inacceptable
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée lg a
annoncé la fermeture de son espace
aérien aux avions militaires français a
rappelé son ambassadeur à paris
aujourd'hui le président français sort
la carte de l'apaisement les précisions
de françois xavier lambert battant et
victimes de guerre trouver les mots
justes pour apaisyl sévère brouille
diplomatique
alors que les relations entre la france
et l'algérie sont au plus bas emmanuel
macron a donc exprimé sa volonté de
calmer les tensions avec alger des
tensions exacerbées en raison de propos
rapportés par le journal le monde le
locataire de l'elysée aurait estimé que
le pays s'était construit depuis son
indépendance sur une rente mémorielle
entretenu par le système politico
militaire
cette fois dans un entretien accordé à
france inter le chef d'état français
déclarent avoir confiance et entretenir
des relations cordiales avec son
homologue abdelmadjid teboul
mon souhait c'est qu'il y ait un
apaisement parce que je pense que c'est
mieux de se parler d'avancée ce n'est
pas un problème diplomatique
c'est d'abord un problème franco
français
j'ai le plus grand respect pour le
peuple algérien et j'entretiens des
relations vraiment cordiale avec le
président est bonne
emmanuel macron n'a en revanche pas
évoqué d'autres propos polémiques dans
lesquelles ils questionnent l'existence
d'une nation algérienne avant la
colonisation française au temps de
parole très mal accueillie par la
présidence algérienne à la suite des
propos non démentis que plusieurs
sources françaises ont attribué
nommément au président de la république
française l'algérie exprime son rejet
catégorique de l' ingérence inadmissible
dans ses affaires intérieures que
constituent les dix propos avant même
cette escalade verbale entre les deux
pays les tension était montée d'un cran
la semaine dernière en cause le choix de
paris de durcir les conditions
d'obtention de visas à l'égard des pays
du maghreb la france a notamment décidé
de baisser de 50% le nombre de visas
délivrés pour les ressortissants
algériens et marocains une nouvelle
politique qui selon paris vise à
convaincre les pays concernés d'accepter
de délivrer des laissez-passer
consulaire nécessaire au rapatriement
des immigrés expulsés de l'hexagone
alger avait dénoncé une décision
disproportionnée
avant de finalement rappelé son
ambassadeur à paris et de fermer son
espace aérien aux avions militaires
français alors ces nouvelles tensions
entre l'algérie et la france hasard du
calendrier ou non une provocation un
appel à la discussion avec la diaspora
algérienne à sept mois de la
présidentielle en france des questions
que l'on se pose ce soir avec frédéric
sinclair éditorialiste
bonsoir salonique sinclair c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'interroger sur ses propos
d' emmanuel macron qui clairement appuyé
un petit peu là où ça fait mal et dans
le même temps cherchent désormais
l'appaisement quelle est votre lecture
avoue
t il il ya deux deux problématiques
peut-être même 3 qui s'entrechoquent la
première c'est une relation de longue
date complexe tant du minet avec le
pouvoir algérien et peut-être même plus
largement avec la la la société
algérienne qui pour une large part à
tisser des liens extrêmement forts avec
une partie de la diaspora qui vit
aujourd'hui en france la question
mémorielle est effectivement une
question
centrale mais elle n'est pas aussi
importante et c'est le deuxième point
finalement de crispation elle n'est pas
aussi importante que veut bien le faire
croire emmanuel macron qui a une
obsession
mémorielle doublé qu'une obsession de la
repentance donc finalement sur cette
question là on se rend bien compte que
il met la question mémorielle à toutes
les sauces et ce mot de rente mémorielle
et extrêmement insultant à l'égard du
pouvoir politique algérien et il ne
traduit rien d'autre que l'obsession
macro nien pour la question de la
mémoire le troisième problème qui est un
véritable problème en soi est à une
question de régulation des flux
migratoires
avec les pays du maghreb mais en réalité
est une question qui se pose plus
largement pour chaque état et cette
question là si elle est aujourd'hui si
mal perçu c'est que emmanuel macron a
effectué un revirement à 180° pendant
quatre ans il n'a absolument pas voulu
se préoccuper des flux entrants en
france et à six mois de la
présidentielle parce qu'eric zemmour
vient taper très fort dans la
fourmilière parce que la droite se
droitise encore plus l air mais
également marine le pen est bien
emmanuel macron pose un acte extrêmement
fort et mal compris parce qu'il n'a pas
été accompagnée des mesures
diplomatiques nécessaires prévenir les
gouvernements marocain j'ai rien
tunisien expliqué qu' il y avait des
circonstances particulières ça n'a pas
échappé je le note la presse algérienne
qui n'a pas manqué de répéter dans ses
colonnes que c'était bien parce qu
emmanuel macron et est en campagne qu'il
réagissait comme ça aujourd'hui
clairement les choses vont quand même
loin pour une sortie peut-être
électoraliste à 6 mois donc de la
présidentielle vous l'avez rappelé alger
qui décident de le rappeler son
ambassadeur qui qui ferme son espace
aérien aux avions militaires français
jusqu'où ça ça peut aller cette petite
crispation voir crise diplomatique
je ne pense pas que ça ira très loin
vous avez vu que le président macron a
déjà donné des signes d'apaisement il
n'est pas un président à vouloir taper
très fort du poing sur la table en
revanche il a manifestement manqué de
sagesse on ne parle pas de cette façon
là même dans une réunion
qui n'est pas directement diffusé sur
les réseaux sociaux ou
télévisées il ya besoin encore une fois
de
diplomatie où on se rend bien compte
qu'ils placent le président tebboune
avec il dit avoir des relations
cordiales dans une situation impossible
où ils isolent finalement de ceux de
cette caste politico militaire qu'il
dénonce et qu'ils condamnent vous voyez
bien que là les propos d'emmanuel
m'apprend sont absolument intenable donc
il fallait qu'il fasse un petit
rétropédalage il l'a fait aujourd'hui on
va rester à mon avis dans cette
situation de crispation parce que la
vraie question qui gênent alger c'est la
question des visas et à juste titre mais
il va y avoir de part et d'autre
probablement à plus ou moins long terme
un certain nombre de signaux positifs
qui vont être envoyés comme ça se passe
à chaque fois est qui et qui vont
apaiser c'est cette crise parmi ces
signaux justement cela concernera les
les visas et dans ce cas et même là
qu'on aura fait son effet d'annonce ans
le suivre vraiment des des faits
derrière il est possible effectivement
il est possible que emmanuel macron
tienne cette ligne un peu ferme jusqu'à
le mois de juin au mois d'avril prochain
que finalement ils cèdent vous savez
qu'il assignait ce pacte de marrakech
qui normalise le principe des des flux
migratoires on a longtemps dit que
c'était une orchestration de migration
outrance n'est pas le cas en revanche il
ya bel et bien une législation qui tente
à normaliser le principe de la migration
si j'ai envie de partir de chez moi dit
le texte eh bien il faut que les états
accompagne monde mon souhait de migrer
ça va dans le sens d'un d'une ouverture
aux pays du maghreb et aux peurs aux
personnes qui sont désireuses de venir
en france est pas et pas l inverse donc
là finalement emmanuel macron est
complètement à contre-courant de ski son
logiciel son adn politique il ya fort à
parier effectivement qu'une fois les
élections présidentielles passées il il
relâche les vannes justement cette
sphère des visas qui concerne également
les marocains et les tunisiens on peut
imaginer la même crispation avec ses ces
deux pays également où l'histoire est
encore plus particulier avec l'algérie
elle est plus particulier vous avez
raison la crispation existe déjà
à rabat il y as au maroc des détentions
7,7 cette fermeture a été mal perçu
ensuite il va falloir voir dans le
détail qui elle concerne vous avez vu qu
emmanuel macron sous l'angle de la
boutade à a dit que les étudiants et les
milieux économiques ne seraient pas
touchés et que finalement ils mettraient
la pression davantage sur les milieux
d'affaires les milieux diplomatiques etc
ce qui était encore une fois mal venu
mais ce qui montre quand même le
l'intérêt qu'y emmanuel macron porte aux
échanges avec les pays du maghreb en
matière économique et estudiantine en
tunisie on a que 30 % de réduction
ddd vise à comparer à 50% pour le maroc
et l'algérie il y a dans tout le maghreb
finalement une histoire depuis 20 à 30
ans extrêmement forte d'aller de retour
avec la france cette logique de
restriction des visas s'inscrit vraiment
dans une politique de droitisation
globale de la france on a vu que même
manuel valls revient sur de façon
critique sur son bilan et parle de la
nécessité de repenser le droit d'asile
de repenser l'accueil d'aider les
familles d'immigrés de conditionner
l'accueil à à l'obtention d'un travail
donc on trouve bien que cette question
de l'immigration est centrale dans le
débat politique français emmanuel macron
ne peut pas l'éviter donc il va falloir
diplomatiquement expliquer ça aux pays
du maghreb merci beaucoup frédéric
sinclair pour cet éclairage ce soir
c'est le fruit de trois ans d'enquêté de
travail la commission indépendante sur
les abus sexuels dans l'église
catholique a rendu son rapport
aujourd'hui depuis 1950 au moins 330
mille mineurs ont été victimes de claire
religieux ou encore de lake en france le
président de la conférence des évêques
de france a exprimé sa honte il demande
pardon victimes qui attendaient des
réponses claires et tangibles de
l'église antoine auger l' enquête menée
en population générale par l'inserm avec
l'appui de l'ifop conduite a estimé dans
la population française âgée de plus de
18 ans à deux cent seize mille le nombre
des personnes qui ont été sexuellement
agressée pendant leur minorité par des
clercs des religieux où les religieuses
deux ans et demi d'enquêté de travaux
regroupés pour arriver à ce nombre
accablant de victimes comptait seulement
entre 1950 et 2020 le président de la
commission indépendante jean marc sauvé
dénonce également dans son rapport la
part de responsabilité de tous les laïcs
travaillant au sein de l'église car si
l'on prend en compte les agressions
commises par des non religieux le nombre
de victimes grimpe à 330 milles le
rapport qui met en lumière les
mécanismes qui ont permis à la
pédocriminalité de persister dans les
sphères religieuses accable l'église
catholique mais représente également un
moyen de faire évoluer les choses la
dimension qualitative de ces recherches
est essentiel et je crois qu'elle fera
date je pense en outre qu'à partir de
ces analyses l'église catholique pourra
ajuster certains aspects par exemple de
la formation de ces prêtres pourra
revoir certains de ses enseignements et
de ses modes de fonctionnement le
rapport montre que les crimes pédophiles
qui ont souvent lieu au sein des
familles dans les écoles ou encore dans
les milieux sportifs sont toujours
nettement plus important dans l'église
catholique objectif de l'enquète en
exposant ses données faire prendre
conscience à la société entière de
l'ampleur du phénomène aux personnes qui
ont été victimes de tels actes de la
part de prêtres de religieux et de
religieuses ou d'autres personnes dans
l'église
j'exprime ma honte mon et froid
ma détermination à agir avec elle vous
dont je connais le nom et le prénom de
quelques-unes et de quelques-uns avec
qui j'ai travaillé et d'autres évêques
avec moi au long de ces dernières années
mon désir en ce jour est de vous
demander pardon au delà du pardon les
victimes réclament un processus
d'accompagnement de la part de
l'institution religieuse mais aussi une
indemnisation financière pour participer
à la réparation des drames vécus
jean-marc sauvé par le non pas de don de
l'église envers ses victimes mais de du
de créances et ça c'est très important
car cela change la donne cela signifie
que l'église doit s'amputer elle-même de
sa capacité financière
accusé de ne pas suffisamment se placer
du côté des victimes dont plusieurs
affaires de pédophilie nalité liée à
l'église le pape françois a réagi au
rapport de jean marc sauvé il a invité
je cite à voir les problèmes en face et
à accompagner les victimes et les
coupables ainsi qu'à accepter le péché
afin de le prendre au sérieux
c'est un dossier qui mêlait mérite paris
dans l'embarras la sphère de l'explosion
de gaz de la rue de trévise qui avait
fait 4 morts et 66 blessés et privés de
toit 300 riverains la mairie de paris et
de syndicats de copropriété de
l'immeuble sont mis en examen notamment
pour homicide et blessures involontaires
33 mois après ce drame
la ville s'apprête à débloquer une aide
pour les victimes
un chèque de 20 millions d'euros pour
alimenter le fonds d'indemnisation
un geste qui ne doit pas être considérée
comme une preuve de culpabilité selon
emmanuel grégoire première adjointe anne
hidalgo et pour en parler justement sur
ce plateau linda zarrou rares présidente
de l'association des victimes et
rescapés de la rue de trévise bonsoir
linda zawahra merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur des français
d'avoir accepté de nous avoir apporté
votre témoignage la mairie de paris qui
annonce donc une alimentation de 20
millions d'euros du fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes de
l'explosion votre état d'esprit est
votre réaction ce soir
notre première réaction enfin la
première pensée va bien sûr à toutes les
victimes à inès inès qui s'est battu
depuis depuis son lit d'hôpital elle a
subi sa 41e opération le 24 septembre il
faut savoir que quand elle est rentrée à
l'hôpital elle avait dans la tête que
elle a reçu un courrier de la sécurité
sociale qui mettait fin à ses droits
donc forcément une pensée pour pour inès
qui a interpellé madame hidalgo dès le
25 septembre
et qui au final on a eu cette réponse de
madame hidalgo grâce effectivement à
l'interpellation thinès maintenant c'est
33 mois 33 mois de de souffrance rentrer
en mode combat de calvaire
trente trois mois où il a fallu
interpellé la mairie de paris l'elysée
où il a fallu interpellé tout le monde
donc certes où il y avait un million
d'euros maintenant
on a rendez-vous demain matin demain
matin avec emmanuelle grégoire à
emmanuel grégoire pardon à la mairie de
paris
attendons de voir comment va s'organiser
tout ça y'a rançon du scepticisme de
votre pas il ya quand même une forme de
soulagement même si on entend que le
combat a été long ce n'a pas été aisée
mais y est il ya une forme de
soulagement aujourd'hui dans le camp des
victimes il ya une forme de soulagement
oui de l'entendre c'est un soulagement
d'être pris en compte enfin pour un
accident collectif de se dire que on est
enfin on va être enfin reconnue en tant
que victime ce statut de victime tant
attendu parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il ya des souffrances des
souffrances au quotidien des difficultés
donc c'est vrai que 33 mois c'est long
33 mois ça malheureusement aggraver la
situation des faits krief des blessés
des victimes grièvement blessées des
postes roma qui sont très lourds
s'aggrave et l'anxiété donc forcément
oui on est soulagé en même temps quand
on voit pour raser dave que en 30 jours
c'est l'accord cadre a été mis en place
quand on voit que pour cru très vite ses
33 mois certes on est soulagés mais on
porte un poids très très lourd sur nos
épaules sauf que là manifestement
l'adjoint à la mairie de paris monsieur
grégoire dit il n'y a pas de culpabilité
dont il ya des victimes et pas de
coupable en tout cas selon la mairie de
paris est ce que c'est ça qui selon vous
a rendu justement difficile le fait
qu'ils aient un accord et cette
indemnisation
il n'y a pas de coupable effectivement
puisqu'une instruction est en cours donc
il faut laisser le temps à la justice de
faire son travail mais en attendant on
n'a pas le droit de laisser les victimes
comme ça sur le côté est vraiment où
personne ne s'occupe d'elle il ya eu des
besoins et des besoins très très
important il ya des situations
dramatiques
certes oui
chacun essayait de
chacun essayait de se couvrir par par
cette culpabilité disant oui je suis pas
coupable mais en attendant il ya des
victimes qui ont souffert ça vous chante
justement que cet adjoint lise voilà il
ne faut pas que ça présume de la
culpabilité parce qu'il y aura une
enquête y aura une enquête en cours
depuis ce genre de déclarations c'est où
c'est le jeu finalement il se pourrait
que la mairie de paris ne soit pas qu'on
passe selon vous c'est quelque chose
qu'on vous envisagez alors nous que ce
soit la mairie de paris grdf peu importe
le coupable au final ce qu'on aurait
aimé ce qu'on aurait voulu c'est que les
victimes soient prises en compte soit
prise en charge dès le 12 janvier 2019
qui n'a pas été le cas
chacun essaye effectivement de la hm2
d'établir une image en disant je ne suis
pas coupable ce n'est pas nous donc je
n'ai indemnise pas parce que je ne suis
pas coupable mais ce qu'il faut penser à
toutes ces victimes à tous et cesser ces
personnes ces travailleurs qui étaient
présents c'est touristes faut penser aux
orphelins parce qu'il ya eu les
orphelins de laura laura qui est décédé
les trois orphelins de laura il ya les
orphelins des pompiers qui sont décédés
aussi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
victimes qui étaient salariés des hôtels
qui ont été grièvement dix handicapés et
criait membres blessés devenus
handicapés ont vu les pompiers explosé
face à eux ils ont vu les ponts qui
mourir donc forcément il ya des
séquelles extrêmement grave et au delà
de la culpabilité on aurait aimé voilà
beaucoup plus d'empathie d'attention et
surtout une vraie prise en charge
aujourd'hui
les critiques sont très sévères envers
la maire de paris anne hidalgo notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux la maire du 9e
arrondissement qui dénoncent elles
clairement un coup d'état médiatique
avec cette aide annoncée évidemment on
est dans la politique là parce que nous
a pas échappé que anne hidalgo et est
candidate à la présidentielle la maire
du 9e n'est certainement pas de son bord
mais est ce que vous vous l'accueillez
de la sorte une forme de coup médiatique
peut-être à cette mort à six mois de la
présidentielle est ce que madame hidalgo
avait le choix face à inès inès une
étudiante en droit qui a travaillé trois
jours qui a explosé sa vie a
complètement explosé ces cas de le dire
elle a subi sa 41e opération
qu'est ce que madame hidalgo avait le
choix effectivement à six mois de
l'élection présidentielle
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que delphine
bürkli nous a beaucoup accompagné donc
forcément delphine bürkli parle avec un
vécu en vécu avec nous à nos côtés donc
je pense que effectivement il ya
effectivement un coup politique
peut-être mais c'est regrettable
aujourd'hui on déplore on déplore le
fait qu'effectivement
on a été au milieu de tout ce jeu
politique et les victimes n'ont pas leur
place là ce qu'on aurait aimé
effectivement c'est une prise en charge
donc oui je pensais sérieusement oui que
madame hidalgo forcément il ya un je
fais mien je viens coup à jouer et
après je ne sais pas si cela va lui
porter préjudice ou pas pour la campagne
présidentielle
aujourd'hui vous attendait autre chose
des autorités quelles qu'elles soient
oui on attend encore puisque ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de on ne sait pas à qui s'adresser
aussi c'est la bataille aujourd'hui pour
toutes les démarches administratives
pour les dossiers mdph pour les les
prises en charge de la cpam donc oui ce
qu'on attend c'est qu'effectivement qui
n'ouvrait prise en charge tout le
système de prise en charge des victimes
est complètement à revoir et on a le
moule et cadets cas vraiment concret qui
aujourd'hui 33 mois après ne sont ou ont
toujours les mêmes difficultés donc oui
on attend un calendrier aussi savoir
emmanuel grégoire a annoncé une
indemnisation les indemnisations avant
le la fin de l'année ok qui quoi comment
les victimes grièvement blessées doivent
être prioritaires dans cette
indemnisation puisque l on et off payer
tous les soins etc et quand on pense à
un l'une des victimes qui a perdu son
eye qui aujourd'hui à des difficultés
pour le remplacement d'une paire de
lunettes parce qu'on a le droit à une
paire de lunettes par an ça c'est pour
tout le monde sauf que lui a beaucoup
plus de difficultés voilà c'est des
sujets sur lesquels les victimes ne
doivent pas s'attarder et ça doit pas
être leur problème merci beaucoup en
tout cas linda zaoura d'être venu
apporter votre témoignage ce soir merci
à vous
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref l'ethiopie ou le
premier ministre a été investi pour un
nouveau mandat de cinq ans habib achmed
et son gouvernement qui doivent faire
face à de nombreux défis parmi lesquels
la guerre aux tigres et qui dure
maintenant depuis quasiment un an un
conflit qui a fait des milliers de morts
ressuscitent de sévères critiques à
l'étranger les relations avec la
communauté internationale se sont encore
dégradées la semaine dernière la raison
l'expulsion de cette responsable d'
agences de l'onu le récit est signée
yamina benguigui
la nouvelle fait l'effet d'une bombe au
sein des nations unies prise de court
par la décision éthiopienne d'expulser
sept de leurs hauts responsables le
gouvernement fédéral éthiopiens qui les
accuse d'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures du pays les a déclarés
persona non grata une mesure jugée
illégale par l'onu et en violation de
leur charte ce que je peux confirmer
c'est qu'aucun des sept membres du
personnel de l'onu nommé par le
gouvernement éthiopien ne se trouve
actuellement dans le pays ils ont été
déplacées hors du pays pour assurer leur
sécurité
une décision qui risque d'aggraver la
situation humanitaire déjà dramatique
sur place
le tigre est soumis à un blocus par
addis abeba voix l'acheminement de
l'aide compliqué voire rendue impossible
depuis la fin du mois de juillet les
nations unies ne sont pas autorisés à
faire entrer du carburant sur le
territoire éthiopien ce qui a poussé à
une réduction des effectifs des
déplacements du personnel de
l'organisation
le conflit qui a démarré dans l'état du
tigre et ne cesse de s'étendre emportant
avec lui les régions voisines afar et
amara cette dernière étant en partie
allié du gouvernement fédéral
dernièrement encore l'armée éthiopienne
et une milice de la région d'amhara se
sont mobilisés à la suite d'une série d'
attaques menées par les forces du tigre
et les tigres est un qui dénoncent des
viols collectifs des massacres et une
famine prémédité par les troupes
gouvernementales et leurs alliés ils ont
donc lancé leurs contre attaques en
prenant cette fois pour cible des civils
de la marée pourquoi pensez-vous que les
forces tigres n ont fait cela pour nous
faire souffrir pour nous faire souffrir
que voulez-vous qu'il arrive au peuple
du tigré
soit éliminé
je veux personnellement qu'il soit
éliminé je veux qu'il soit éliminé
combien de personnes avons nous perdu
combien d'animaux avons nous perdu
combien de bétail avons nous perdu mon
père est mort je suis prêt à me battre
ou on imagine poule invaincue
cette guerre qui a commencé en novembre
dernier a provoqué le déplacement de
centaines de milliers de personnes et
causé des milliers de morts
majoritairement des civils l'ethiopie
traverse la pire crise alimentaire de la
décennie avec environ 400000 personnes
confrontées à la famine on reste sur le
continent africain direction la côte
d'ivoire où le gouvernement entend
lutter contre la corruption les
opérations coup de poing dans les
services publics se multiplient dans le
viseur tout particulièrement le racket
de la population la correspondance
abidjan de 10 la fameuse ou
des pots-de-vin pour être admis à un
concours accélérer l'obtention d'un
passeport ou se voir délivrer un faux
permis de conduire la corruption affecte
tous les pans de la vie quotidienne
c'est le constat amer de ses habitants
de yopougon l'une des communes les plus
peuplées du district d'abidjan n'est pas
tout au fait c'est pas tout suivi d'un
peu de soupe est bonne tout passe via
les médias qui sont prescrits sur
ordonnance et il faudrait forcément
d'avoir la maladie a vendu à bâle
d'obtenir cette indolence mais avec un
peu d'argent bon petit donné on peut des
données lors de noces en octobre et
signer tout ça tout donner pour que tous
aient accès à la pharmacie ou avalé
beaucoup maintenant on demande certaines
choses
car trop de corruption il faut que
l'état revoie issa aucun doute nous qui
sommes jeunes nous puissions avoir un
boulot l'opinion est épanoui en fait le
policier bon j'ai pas dit qu'ils vont
ils font pas le travail en tant que tel
on ne travaille
van damme fait ils prennent de l'âge
normalement vous quand vous arrêter
quelqu'un vous devez donner un papier
mais a l'impression que maintenant il
faut qu'on nous déloge même si tu as
raison la paraison tu dois donner de
l'argent la côte d'ivoire est classée
104e sur 180 en matière de corruption
par les ong transparency international
le gouvernement dit vouloir combattre ce
fléau généralisé est de plus en plus
dénoncée par les citoyens un ministère a
même été créé pour lutter contre le
racket et restaurer la confiance entre
la population et l'état nous sommes en
train de mettre en place une plate forme
de signalement des cas de corruption ou
les usages et les populations les
personnes intéressées tous ceux qui sont
témoins victimes et qui ont intérêt à ce
que la collection s'arrête dont une
plateforme où toutes ces personnes
peuvent aller et signaler les cas de
corruption et pas derrière l'équipe du
ministère va faire de la vérification
des actions fortes ont été menées dans
plusieurs secteurs problématiques et
plus particulièrement au sein de la
police et la gendarmerie mais pour cette
organisation de la société civile la
guerre contre la corruption est loin
d'être gagné c'est tout un système qui
est gangréné il y a au moins cet
ivoirien / / / 10 qui estime que le
gouvernement
n'aborde pas bien la question de la
corruption et la plupart d'entre eux
fustigé le manque de sanctions que ce
soit au niveau au niveau judiciaire du
système judiciaire le saut au niveau du
gouvernement ou au niveau 2
je veux dire à du parlement
de la poésie agenda mairie et des régies
financières
ils les enquêtes montrent bien que c'est
la corruption n'épargne aucun secteur
dans une enquête publiée en 2010 cette
part l'institut afrobaromètre un
ivoirien sur deux déclare payé des
pots-de-vin aux forces de l'ordre et un
sur trois ans reconnaît avoir déjà payé
des agents administratifs pour obtenir
des documents c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous demain dès 20
heures en attendant l'actualité continue
toute la soirée sur arte france
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
depuis vingt ans les investissements de
pékin sont telles que l'on parle de la
chine afrique reste à savoir si pour le
continent africain il s'agit d'un
partenariat gagnant ou perdant la chine
a besoin non seulement des matières
premières mais les marchés
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui un témoignage fort
sur le deuil d'un fils stéphane al